[Music]
yes we do have some questions here
there's just one question i this one
comes from judith quite i'll pose it
perhaps you have it in your mind already
who is the uncountable people
um that paul saw apart from the one
hundred forty and four thousand
i it wasn't paul it was john
there we go uh john revelation seven
verse nine after this i looked and
behold a great multi-generational minded
number of all nations and kindreds and
people in town stood before the throne
and before the lamb it's a great
multitude and 144 000. now some
theologians say it's the same thing i
don't see how it is the same thing 144
000 a select group then there's a larger
multitude and so that's what john is
seeing because 144 000 are alive when
christ comes there's a vast muslim
that's dead the righteous dead they have
to be raised so we have two groups
we have two groups on monk
transfiguration with jesus elijah
represented those who never died moses
represent those who died on rose and so
we have two groups
but the same destination
amen amen amen
you